just we're gonna do but how about how
[ __ ] is he most what you got for me
catch of a friend but it can work rather
they didn't get comfortable I mean wait
one second zoo listen carefully there's
a boat pulling in soon with a cargo
container full of girls the morning
stars new merchandise I send you the
details and you hit the boat because I
don't know who the hell this is but
viola de winter really well as much as I
value career advice from the [ __ ] that
killed my friend with me and he'll good
do whatever you want with it the most
things have changed let's hope that's a
good thing okay so as I sit so far away
what is that over there see that all
right
is that like a nuclear power plant as
little [ __ ] hmm well man this place is
[ __ ] big even with flying it takes a
while Jesus anyways let's do this match
as let's do this I'm rocking all over
the place oh [ __ ] get this ain't gettin
dizzy ok ok
respect cats good I guess thank ya yeah
should I get that thing yet know how
goes it after this
ok ok ok
not shut shut shut can't [ __ ] dense a
clam out fire mother oh yes again oh we
got to take that down let's test how to
push it on that thing and once it's ours
the morning star sex operation is done
are you gonna move all the [ __ ] a lot
pictures and just let me worry about
that now let's go I want to meet my new
employees okay [ __ ] backwards you
[ __ ] idiot chase us so these girls
gonna try to kill us to being shot by
hose sticks with you
ok what is laying on their you want to
get off and swim just checking
well [ __ ] [ __ ] this
I can I wow them to me I keep them sick
what's all gone that's right there you
go that's I what pistols kind of a gal
okay bae
I'm still the best Oh locate hope grades
ok I found one
now is here just a bunch of Delta
starving change this can I [ __ ] up
okay this is a hook right let's go got a
hose in here okay I got a couple hollers
good with the Z and a house any hair any
i can now how's that good singer nades
that out okay Andy how's it here that's
a hoe check how check oh good good nice
doc they have okay anywhere has any
warehouse [ __ ] dick sauce your boxing
these guys
oh shut konkan ate that [ __ ] ganado
we're gonna [ __ ] it out
okay good good okay where's yeah the
whole check ho check Oh check any house
in here any house in here how can tell
does how can tell bit before so tired of
fighting del does that guy behind me
lies i think a man what is wrong with
these guys [ __ ] hey Oh cares all
right here oh yeah that's def by some
house in here huh how's your Freya Frey
thank you for freeing me go to him and
stay close yeah keep you safe sugar [ __ ]
we have to get past that guy what guy
what guy
come on come on this sucking shut
oh great how odd come on oh [ __ ] Oh
smack that [ __ ] yeah pop it just a
pretty face I don't need a [ __ ]
minigun are you any hair [ __ ] ass again
here [ __ ] I got a good girl you'll be
safe with that pimp hear anything I
don't ya made you a fine little thing ok
here greats never end ok got the house
these [ __ ] up before you began see
everyone in the crate moving ok the [ __ ]
hurry they're coming for the boat oh
great because on some big fire baba
layin on those platforms on the sides
okay oh [ __ ] I ain't getting so close
until it's clear down there okay okay
I'll line up shut we're just the sound
is so [ __ ] slow okay that's another
MIG oh hello beautiful okay [ __ ]
okay okay oh [ __ ] [ __ ] my dick sauce
[ __ ]
nice chef older model coming in
yeah but there's a lot of them
the pride
ah [ __ ] huh [ __ ] is she any of it has to
be embarrassing
[ __ ] a
okay oh [ __ ]
good good good hey Dad cut wow that was
exciting let's love these holes up there
and get the hell out of here that has
kind of feelings set up here morningstar
always protect that shipment it ain't
nothing new isn't this a lot of guards
though always say Bush is big business
in this town just okay yeah okay that's
our grad to
okay I got oh shet get tied up pierce
your God [ __ ] is wrong with these
[ __ ]
oh is it boss me I got this keep moving
ok
ah haters gonna hate okay [ __ ] is gone
out of the ditch
if you need to lock on for these [ __ ]
okay oh [ __ ]
another
[ __ ]
okay it's not another one yeah
why are they aiming
Barry gather I got [ __ ]
we got our hose like they're so mad
Oh [ __ ] a bloody is that but still
hanging time peers chart a bold anything
give me a sec to Clara mouth
oh my god yeah huh
okay good yeah about a house my house
okay what else what else
hey focus on flying will ya
05 [ __ ] they're all over the [ __ ]
place oh shut
oh this is such an insane so this is
okay I got now oh [ __ ] I did enter a
long bet you still dangling can't be
good
okay he's calling me now you have
something that belongs to me and that's
so who the hell is this someone who's
winning sparking bring the girls back to
the morning star and i'll pay you top
dollar ahead let me consider it that's
all I not was that about morning star o
by the girl's back no I can't do my
thing if I got no [ __ ] to sell the
money won't come quick but you better go
calm okay thank God
true dr. Bravo or saints headquarters
since
okay I gotta make a decision I'm again
I'm gone with the Saints itches okay I'm
going with the Saints you're with us
four raisins emos get to pimp in those
girls okay what the hell are you
thinking Mary it just seemed like a
waste to lose all those girls I am the
general I'm the Czar under walking
apocalypse and I make the design in here
my bad so what happens now yeah we found
out we focus we don't do a running we
hit him with a Montreal screw drop the
[ __ ] of that yeah yeah that's it no
listen up my esteemed colleagues the
time is now we have deployed stag to
steal for jay says what the [ __ ] you
stay what does it stand for anyways
thanks for watching guys thank ya
dicks out for her Amish